hi my name is James Nava I am the sound
supervisor predominantly on large studio
movies tentpole movies they call them I
think Harry Potter clash of the titans
Sherlock Holmes and as such and I've
been in the industry for 22 years
started as an apprentice and one of the
things that I think I've learnt is that
there are three main attributes that
help with this profession one is the
ability to collaborate to to listen and
to understand and the technical ability
needed to operate the editing systems
that we work on ProTools predominantly
and the other is is the ability to allow
yourself to follow your creative flair
if you think something is going to work
go for it in layman's terms as a sound
supervisor I'm the person that works
directly with the Creator the director
and the producer and the director will
give me his briefers to Harry like the
film to sound and I will then look at
the people I think might be relevant for
that process and I'll suggest that
they're the people that they use so i
will try and put together a crew that I
think the director and the producer will
work well with we then move forward and
we start building the soundscape and my
role is to orchestrate this soundscape
including elements of the music but
ultimately getting the material
developing the material and supplying it
throughout the process of editorial so
that by the time we get to temps and
premixes they're aware of everything
that they want they've signed off on
everything they want and then my final
part of the role will be sitting the
dubbing theatre during all the mixes and
to orchestrate and translate what the
director wants because he can't be there
all the time and so I oversee the sound
from the beginning to the end of the the
process
how's he grading over ya been trained to
expect pain when I hear the noise the
thing that changes the most in the sound
is usually the design and the effect
elements because the nature of the
rhythm of the cut will dictate how the
sound elements need to work with that so
that's an escape is constantly moving
and changing past a certain point you
find that the new elements are coming in
less but the resyncing of everything is
happening all the way through up to the
very last minute one of the most
engaging moments there are so many mer
are so many great moments that we had
when we were working on Harry Potter and
I but I think one of the proudest
moments for me is always when you come
up with a new idea or a new sound that
has to convey a story line and and one
of the one of the crucial things that we
do and we should never lose sight of is
that we're there to enhance and
embellish the story and if we try and
step on the feet of the story we're
doing our job badly we should always
follow suit and make sure that
everything's clear and in Harry Potter
there are several occasions where
subtext was being told through sound
design and sound effects and in harry
potter six i believe we're about seven a
part one we used we were required to
develop a sound to convey the Horcrux
and it was such an important part of the
storytelling motif and it had to carry
through the whole film and it had to be
nasty it had to be threatening it had to
be specific we had to understand that's
exactly what we were hearing at the same
time in the film they were radio
airwaves so it couldn't be too FM sort
of twisted air wave sounds but it had to
have something like that and we spent
weeks recording everything we could find
we took a part of piano we recorded
scraping piano strings we managed to get
some vuvuzela because it was the year of
the
old cup and everybody was complaining
about this horrible sound vuvuzela so we
thought well that's a horrible sound
nobody likes that maybe that'll work we
use sirens we used a whole menagerie of
different sounds that might relate to
people might pique people's interest or
empathy with what we were trying to do
and when we finally got the sound the
assault of it and the in your head pneus
of it the sort of the grating fingers
down the chalkboard element worked
really well and I think those things can
often be those those very simple or
seemingly very simple elements can often
be the thing that doesn't actually get
right until the very last stage
everybody feels that they're struggling
to really believe it and we nailed it
very early on and it gave us a wonderful
opportunity to use different parts of
that all the way through the story so a
certain element of the Horcrux would
apply to a certain character at a
certain time and it meant you always
kept in with this uneasy feeling that
had to purvey the film so that was a
real that was a yeah we were all very
proud or managed to get that simple but
very effective
they've added the Gemma no cash
everything you touch will multiply give
in sauce
directors are very individual people and
they're very they bring something to
every film and every script that's very
important and their vision their final
part of their of their journey as it
were is post-production audio and so
that part of the process is a very very
delicate very personable and very
important stage it's about letting go
it's about feeling that you've done
everything you can to make this creation
and so my relationship with directors is
very often to to make sure that I
understand what they want from the first
point that will change always through
the process that changes but it's very
important to know where they're going
with the changes to accommodate those
changes and then to make sure that they
are ideally they want to feel as though
everything that they want they're
getting and something else and that
they're happy to let go my advice to
anybody starting in it or has an
interesting sound for film or has an
interest in filmmaking it's very
important to to address all areas and
find out where your strengths are
without doing them you won't know and I
think people who who really benefit from
doing that people who will go and film
their own they'll go and film their own
films with on a video camera or whatever
they're using but they'll also record
the sound and they'll take a small
recorder and go and record their own
wild tracks and they'll go and see what
works how close you have to be how far
away you have to be and I think that's
the first stage of gaining experience
but also gaining an insight into what
you're really interested in because it
will change throughout the process
there's no reason why you should ever be
in the same role or in the same part of
the industry they it needs you on as you
grow thru it to different different
aspects
you